Millie Foster is hoping to start a family soon,
but her prenatal regimen will be more complicated than most women's because she has a condition called PKU
PKU, phenylketonuria, is a rare inherited disorder where a person lacks a crucial enzyme needed to break down
an amino acid called phenylalanine
When PKU is not controlled properly, high levels of phenylalanine, or Phe, are toxic
to both the brain and body and can lead to serious health complications.
Foster: “I'm very vigilant about that right now.
It's given me a really good reason, a good motivation, to on track my Phe levels on a daily basis
and to watch what I eat and to do whatever it takes to have a healthy baby.”
Today Millie is a dietitian and spends part of her summer as a counselor here at Emory’s metabolic camp.
The camp was created to help teach girls with PKU how to keep their Phe levels from getting too high.
The girls learn about healthy eating options while avoiding foods high in protein which can spike Phe levels.
Dr. Rani Singh founded and directs the camp.
Singh: "“The earlier we detect, the earlier we diagnose, and the earlier we intervene, the more we protect the brain."
But pregnant women with PKU face special challenges like the threat of having a child with developmental delays even if her baby doesn't have PKU.
“They’ll still be at a very high risk for what we call the maternal PKU syndrome. It's like fetal alcohol syndrome.”
Maternal PKU refers to any number of fetal abnormalities that result from an expecting mother with PKU who has excessive Phe levels in her blood.
So even though a woman with PKU may not have symptoms herself, because she's adhered to a restrictive diet throughout her youth,
her baby could still face devastating consequences if she lapses during pregnancy.
Stanojevich: “I knew going into the pregnancy — because of camp — the risks for a child with a mother that has PKU,
including microcephaly, which is a small head, which also leads to cognitive development issues,
and I knew that congenital heart defects is a risk,
as well as slight risk of craniofacial deformities and growth restriction.”
Martha Stanojevich is a former camper who as an adult has given birth to one healthy daughter and is expecting her second.
“I think the most important things that I've done it in both pregnancies is tracking my daily intake.
I weigh and measure everything that I eat and then I track it every single day
and I also count milligrams of Phe, which is the most precise measurement.”
“It's so important for the mother to be on a strict diet
and have her Phe levels under control to avoid the toxicity to the developing baby.”
Both Martha and Millie are better able to manage their PKU in part because of the strategies they learned here as teens.
“I remember learning at a very young age about the importance of dietary control during pregnancy, nd it was something that was reinforced time and time again as I was here.
And so when it became time for my husband and I to plan our first pregnancy, we had good knowledge of what to expect and knew that planning was essential.
I think the camp was completely responsible for that.”